what do you what did you get from
working on that series i mean how
difficult was it
it was
well
it was challenging in that it was only
my second job so
i still when i you know when i look back
on the show i can see how green i was
and i was just and i'm still a sponge i
still look at myself as i mean i don't
think i'll ever not be the the new girl
in my mind you know yeah well i read
somewhere that you like always you love
to work with people that are i guess
better than you or more experienced so
you can learn more totally punch above
my weight like you know always because i
want to learn and i learn from even
people making mistakes or people not
making you know the choices that's
needed and scenes i learned from just
watching
um
but in that show i learned the real and
i actually pulled a lot of the
importance of what like makeup and
costume can do for a character and i
brought that into a maze on lucifer you
know she had like
you could you could tell a lot about who
she was by how she presented herself how
she walked
into a room right um
i learned
a lot about
and i didn't know i i guess it was
trusting my instincts about like
you know protecting yourself in a set
with nudity and like what you were
comfortable with and just being very uh
so you had to be nude yes so i i did you
had never done that before no bums and
boobs
bombs and boobs bobs and boobs is what i
did i did not do the
merkin stuff it was not my jam were you
nervous
no i muddled before so well you didn't
model nude
yeah but you're like backstage and
you're like whipping your stuff over
yeah yeah
i've never been hung up for me what was
more important was
gratuitous nudity that was not something
i was into right so
i remember
like one of my co well the costume they
wanted me to do was like basically
a piece of fabric and then you just have
this like boob out
but my chastity was being preserved
by my boss as a gift
and i was like her right-hand person so
i go well story-wise lying that doesn't
make sense
at all
i'm not walking around with a
teddy whipped out like
for an entire season
i'm not comfortable
um this is what i'll give you and so
that was what i was going to i'll give
you some signed boobs i'll let you go
side boob
uh that's what i'm comfortable with but
these but i didn't i was having these
sorts of conversations
you know without pre metoo and all of
that sort of stuff and yeah i i really
do credit like being raised in cape town
honestly and like my dad was like you
don't do anything anymore you don't do
anything you don't allow anyone to make
you do something you don't want to do
like that was always drilled into my my
head